thank you you just say thank you for
really applauding a nut Rand palling it
you know what I'm talking about this
this is an amazingly a week of a lot of
fake scandals and one real one we'll get
to that but here's my favorite fake when
you saw on Tuesday the Prime Minister of
Israel spoke before Congress the
Republicans [ __ ] love this guy I I
thought they were gay for Reagan but I
mean they were jumping up and down like
they're ready Taylor Swift concert and
okay but here's the scandal the next day
all these repeal of these conservative
outlets got on Rand Paul the Kentucky
Senator because he wasn't clapping
enthusiastically enough because we live
in North Korea now people like you and
the next day Rand Paul said I gave the
man 50 standing ovations one for each
Jew in Kentucky
what are you wanting to play Tevye and
feather on the Rope puppy apparently
they do a meet that Republicans went all
out Ted Cruz was wearing Star of David
face paint and a clip-on beard Lindsey
Graham is throwing his panties right at
bebe it was amazing Mitch McConnell was
running around showing everybody is
circumcision I mean now of course they
did it to get Obama's goat but you know
Obama got the last laugh this week
because another fantastic jobs report
came out at analyst analyst say the
economy is an ideal shape for a
Republican to come in and wreck it again
in 2016 isn't that good now listen to
this
295 thousand new jobs last month
unemployment is down to 5.5 percent
which the Fed says is full employment
for the first time since 1977
private-sector job growth has exceeded
200,000 for 12 consecutive months or is
[Applause]
or as they report on Fox News Hilary
used the wrong email like obey humanity
she used her own email address instead
of the office one ladies and gentlemen
this is a calamity the likes of which
this country has never seen I'll never
forget where I was when I learned that
four brave Americans were cc'd on the
wrong server yes it turns out the
Clintons had set up their own personal
Clinton email dot-com account and people
are shocked Democrats got a website to
work
[Applause]
curry says it was all a big mistake she
said after bill used the internet the
keyboard keys would stick and that's why
she what I heard John McCain yesterday
he said McCain said he doesn't use email
at all he said because you know with my
temper I just don't trust him
okay you know what grandpa we know
that's not why you don't use email
Republicans are not the most tech-savvy
people in the world McCain thinks
megabytes is the Secret Service codename
for chris Christie so we are coming up
on the 50th anniversary of the
groundbreaking civil rights march in
Selma Alabama and no one can forget the
no one can forget the images from that
horrible day when police with fire hoses
and dogs and clubs viciously attacked
Bill O'Reilly so President Obama and
dozens of people from Congress are
gathering there to commemorate the event
and police from Ferguson Missouri say
there also be there to hand out
jaywalking tickets yeah now that's the
real scandal I was talking about you see
what when I the Justice Department being
released a report about what was going
on in Ferguson Missouri apparently the
entire town is basically a scheme run by
racist cops to arrest black people not
just arrest them and harass them but
then finance the town with the tickets
and the fines on the police cars right
on the side have said to collect and
serve all right and now what you really
care about
Harrison Ford he's fine his condition
has been upgraded from cranky to grumpy
as I am sure you know by now Harrison
Ford owns a vintage world war two era as
most of us do plane which crashed at a
golf course here in LA and he's
something of a hero because when the
engine failed he managed to avoid
crashing into houses thus preserving the
rights of future celebrities to fly
dangerous antique aircraft over major
cities how about that ladies and
gentlemen hero now it really is an
amazing story because when the plane
crashed two doctors who happen to be
golfing rescued him and treated him and
possibly saved his life people are
calling it a miracle doctors working on
their golf day